would you rather [__] the most hideous
girl in the world or an average looking
guy I mean dude come on I mean guys I
mean dude I've many average looking guys
I mean what do you mean dude yeah and I
mean the Hideous girl in the world that
dude that doesn't mean anything to me
dude when you're I would have peace with
anything dude I would have messed with
an animal I would have messed with
anything at all any point in the day I
would 100 though I'm gonna tell you this
if you put a beautiful girl next to an
average looking guy but the average
looking guy had a better personality
he'd have a better shot of me having
them than the hot girl with no
personality dude it's not gay okay if
you want to literally subscribe to we're
all human and the human race and there's
no gender and there's no then who gives
a love who you love have sex with who
you want to have sex with and don't
matter don't worry the gay means nothing
to me okay I like people and I'll have
to the person and uh yeah I'm gay